hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse orange comm and in this video
we're going to go over how to use an AED
on an adult and a child eight years or
older now if you are going to be
recertifying for your CPR class you're
going to be taking CPR you will be
learning how to use one of these this is
a sample one it's a training device and
you will definitely encounter this so I
wanted to make this video just to help
you brush up your skills before you take
your recertification and you can be
prepared before you go to class so let's
get started what is an AED an ad that is
short for automatic external
defibrillator and what these things are
they are great and whenever you're doing
CPR typically what happens is that the
first person who finds the victim they
call 9-1-1 and they go get an AED or if
you have someone with you they'll go get
the ad for you and while they're going
you'll be doing CPR now whenever the AED
arrives you'll want to do some steps
which I'm going to demonstrate for you
here in a second and on what the AED
does is it analyzes the victims rhythm
and if the victim isn't v-fib or
pulseless v-tach which are absolutely
lethal resident rhythms meaning that the
person is fixing to die this thing will
shock it and hopefully reset their heart
and they go back into sinus rhythm and
come back to life because they are dying
and but there are some things that you
want to take in consideration whenever
you're using the ad which I'll go over
here in a second if the victim has a
hairy chest what are you going to do if
you're there submerged in water or their
chest is wet what do you do if they have
an implanted device on their chest like
a pacemaker sub-q port or something like
that where do you place these pads and
um transdermal patches what do you do if
you see a nitroglycerin patch or a
morphing patch or something on their
skin how do you handle that so the ad
looks like this they do look do
this is just one type and it has the
green button is your on button they are
so simple to use like it tells you
everything to do you turn this button on
and then it'll tell you to connect to
this with your pads which I'll show you
here in a second and then it will say
analyzing and then whenever it's ready
to shock you look at this yellow button
right here of course clear the patient
and everything and it just tells you
everything to do and you have different
sets of pads now on adults and children
you want to use adult pads okay this is
what adult pads look like and on the
little pads they show you where they go
so it's awesome if you're an emergency
situation and here's the little
connector that goes in that port and
just I want to show you this because I
am going to be making a video how to use
a navy on an infant and these are
pediatric pads on how you use them on an
infant so let me show you how to use an
ad on an adult or child above 8 or older
okay so you're performing CPR and your
second CPR person has came back with the
ad you would keep doing CPR until the
ADEs ready to analyze because no one
needs to touch the patient because it
could cause artifact and the ad might
think the patients in v-fib and they're
not in shock when the patient didn't
need to be shocked or whenever the
patient's getting ready to be shocked no
one needs to be touching the patient so
you'll keep it in CPR and then the
second seat person will hook up with the
AED while you're doing CPR and if you're
all by yourself of course you would stop
and you would use the AED so we're going
to use ad the ad has arrived the very
first thing you want to do is you want
to make sure look at the patient's chest
remember those four things I was talking
about if they have a hairy chest you'll
if there's a razor in the kit some kids
have razors try to quickly trim the
hairs where the patches will go they
normally go here in here which I'll go
over here in a second the right upper
will go on the right upper chest below
the collarbone and then the other one
will go right here below the left nipple
at the top edge where the top edge of
the pad just a few inches below the
armpit and then pads we'll show you that
say you didn't have a razor and some
AG's come with extra pads and you could
just take a pad and just rip the hair
off and do that because you have to get
that hair off if possible because if not
it might not deliver the greatest shot
because that hair is acting like a
barrier now if the patient was submerged
in water you have to move the patient
out of the water because electricity and
water do not go well together you will
get electrocuted it wouldn't be good and
if there's a lot of water on the
patient's chest you can dry them off
with a towel or something
now the patients in snow or in a small
puddle it's okay you you would be fine
now if the patient has an implanted
device like a pacemaker defibrillator
anything like that it's usually a big
lump in the chest you can really feel it
you wouldn't want to put an ad pad over
that you want to put it away from it
because the implanted device could stop
the transmission of the shocking to the
heart can mess it up and also the
patient had a transdermal patch like
nitroglycerin or morphine patch any type
of medication patch we want to take that
off and clean just wipe it off because
it could burn the skin and that wouldn't
be good so you get your ad the very
first thing you want to do is turn it on
so turn it off is a training device only
no shot will be delivered I just don't
as the talks not gonna be delivered
because it's training persons just you
would remove the clothing from the
person says of course because you're
doing CPR so fully already be removed
attach pads firmly to persons chest hey
you in the fat there's usually some pads
and you're gonna get your pads out and
this is gonna go go get one and press it
down firmly like a victory [ __ ] and
then put it underneath the armpit right
below the nipple line right here and
press sorry Thank You Victor a pitch and
then we're going to connect right here
with a lot flashing - Thank You Victor
analyzing rhythm everyone stand if
everyone would want to be clear so
holler clear
shock advised and stored your socks I
mean look stop here everyone stand clear
push the shock button and you would say
clear and everyone's clear and then hit
shock shock delivered begin five cycles
of CPR and then you would get back on
the chest and you would do CPR and this
little thing has a little time of the
rid of your fist ago you do five cycles
which would equal two minutes and then
this thing would reanalyze and shock if
that was needed so that is how you use
an ad on a child or an adult